youtube we are back weekly v nft nyc
week i think this is loaded i hope you
enjoy it i miss you all tremendously
you do not love losing you lost
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and to be very frank with you economics
are not my driver so so much of my
behavior is counter-cultural for a
businessman hence the book you're
reading the argument i'm trying to make
is if you actually cared about good
things i have a funny feeling all these
things that all of you want has a much
better chance of getting there like i'm
the alpha of my hypothesis but then what
makes it feel like it has validity is
i'm not just looking at me i'm watching
very carefully and i'm like wait a
minute the nice people actually are
winning long term bad people can win in
the short term but reputation matters
look what's going on in our society
we're having a massive collective day of
reckoning with bad behavior right and i
will spend the rest of my life trying to
change popular culture around this issue
[Music]
i think the number one line on a bill of
rights of a leader is you must eliminate
fear from your team it's why kind candor
really [ __ ] with me when it got clear
as [ __ ] that my inability to be candace
to people actually created fear in my
companies because people didn't know if
they would get fired out of nowhere it
was the lowest point in my professional
career because i realized i had failed
in my ambition to eliminate fear i
should have never let well listen that's
that's unfair i grew up in a way dna
wise parenting and circumstance and the
way i naturally navigated that really
demonized confrontation and i've refined
it now undressing somebody
inappropriately in a room is very
different than not being able to go to
somebody in a separate meeting sit down
and respectfully and kindly deliver
critical feedback but i viewed all
critical feedback as negative because
most of what i saw with critical
feedback in my youth was delivered so
poorly that i was unable to dissect the
vessel delivering the feedback from the
value of feedback
see you brother cheers so much bye-bye
okay
yeah it was 12.
this is it so yeah 12-brosis used to be
a co-working space called sunshine
suites and this is where vaynermedia
started mike boyd's interviews from that
viral clip put it right here right now
for doing a dailyvee of like mac miller
interviews we're done in there wow yeah
honestly yeah it's just so like all
these interactions all this time this is
really the first time i felt like this
since 2007. austin in a confined area
for south by is probably a little bit
better because it's just new york's so
[ __ ] big and it's all over but it's
the same feeling like meeting people
that you met on twitter in real life
back then was the first time that ever
happened and like the way the nft macro
ecosystem is working is very similar to
web 2. different because we're more
mature it's like the internet is more
true but it's still the same feeling of
like
wow i'm like really interacted with
these people i really kind of it's a
real community and now we're meeting in
real life
[Music]
1979 it's almost mid there's a little
like thing this is for me yes i'm going
to put this on my shelf
drock make sure i do that
drock just informed me that this is
weekly v not dailyvee so i apologize for
the prior reference
the reason i came so hard to nfts is
because the sports card industry was
pushing me out because they thought i
was pumping and dumping when i didn't
sell a single [ __ ] sports card with
this world you could follow me you could
see my behaviors so i'm like this is
[ __ ] awesome this is transparency you
can see what i'm doing it's all right
there [ __ ] you i would never ruin my
[ __ ] reputation to make eight dollars
on a [ __ ] kevin durant rookie card
you [ __ ]
i
idiot
enough money long ago you think i'm
really gonna pump some [ __ ] [ __ ]
pfp project to make 80 000 in 24 hours
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not and i know a
lot of people do but that's why i came
to this world but i don't want the power
i don't i do not want it there's nothing
in it for me
talking to my mirror like i love you so
much
curving all my critics like i heard you
so what
you can't kill my confidence i think i'm
the man
um oh this is really cool
[Music]
because people have invested
extraordinary levels of money into your
art do you feel like you have to execute
for the next years to justify those
costs and does that weigh on you like
how does that sit with people there is
pressure but it's not hard for me
because at the end of the day i was
doing this for free for 20 years i was
getting up and trying really [ __ ]
hard to make digital art the best i
could for 20 years before anybody gave a
[ __ ]
before anybody would pay for it and so
that's where it was like wait so now
people are gonna pay up and so i think
at the end of the day all i can do is
get up and try really [ __ ] hard and
that's it and like that's what i was
doing before and that's what i'm doing
now and so that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
my old friend you look exactly the same
that's not true but it's great to see
you
backstage nft nyc i have a dream with my
coffee today you have cream in your
pocket
oh good coffee
this [ __ ] got very weird
[Music]
new york what's good
when it's on the pre-dawn of the moment
that's when i jump kevin rose and i are
talking and he's thanking me because i
got him to buy some jordan rookies at a
really low price and we're really
nerding it the [ __ ] out and then he goes
do you have a punk and i'm like what's a
punk
and he dropped three minutes on crypto
punks i had a run because the family
something and then that night started a
45 to 75 hour journey over a one week
period where i consumed everything about
crypto punks and by mid-january i
decided that i was gonna buy a lot of
them at that point because of what i was
already doing i had felt we were close
to the time so you felt december last
year was the pre-dawn yes and then you
went all in all in what about a couple
of questions from the audience and then
we'll we'll move on
gary what's up tomorrow i'm going to be
minting a crypto new yorker and i
nominated you to join our community the
community voted and you won if you're
free i would love to bring you what time
three
wow
go clap it's highly unlikely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's
i think it's executing within discord
and twitter okay and it's like you know
everybody sees this version of me yeah
nobody saw the 2007 version of me that
lived on twitter for 11 hours a day for
four years it's always the reps you put
in the way to break above the noise is
to put in the work
and get [ __ ] lucky
you know what's funny i think yeah look
i think the media under reports the luck
factor i think luck is real but i think
luck is an incredibly dangerous thing to
attach yourself to because then it
becomes your excuse look i was born in
the soviet union i'm lucky to even be in
this country i'm lucky because my mom
built self-esteem like i believe in luck
i'm lucky that all this [ __ ] came out
when i was alive i could have been born
in the 40s but i also believe if i was
born in the 40s with all the same [ __ ]
that i would own seven fruit stands and
have a good life and have a good you
know what i mean don't fall in love with
luck it leads to a lot of unhappiness
i'm just saying it's underrepresented
and i'm saying whether it's true or not
if you have a relationship with luck
that you deploy against everybody else
you will never be in a good place
promise brother yeah i promise with all
my [ __ ] heart
[Music]
that was definitely something i mean
that [ __ ] that i was just in that's not
comfortable for most people yeah you
take time i know yeah i appreciate that
gary it's the thing that somebody wants
people want to be heard and by the way
i'm not doing it because i know they
want to be heard i'm doing it because i
want to hear them
like that's what i'm trying to teach
people it's like if you're not doing it
for the right reason it doesn't matter
if you do the right tactics sure
[Music]
i'm like spending more time on diverse
artists and projects than the other
stuff that's what i can do about it and
i'm like i'm not going to preach people
into doing [ __ ] about it because i've
come to learn at my older age that [ __ ]
doesn't work that makes you feel better
the only thing i can worry about is what
i do and i have a platform where enough
people watch that it may have some
collateral and we have to take our own
[ __ ] responsibilities and i want to
put real effort time and money to just
give what the reality is which is how do
you put people on second base
it's okay
hi buddy i was doing an interview
earlier and the people who were
interviewing me were like gary's doing
like 60 interviews a day like so there's
11 gary's roaming there was somebody who
genuinely genuinely once wrote me about
two years ago a very complex
science-based email genuinely asking me
if i cloned myself and i googled him and
he's like this like hardcore scientist
in europe and like really like broke it
down it was like in a weird way like the
greatest compliment of all time
[Music]
i have a lot of love for a lot of you
that we haven't interacted with that i
know and obviously extra love for the
people i have interacted with i just
wanted to thank you and more importantly
i just want to thank avery who runs
vayner nft and is a major partner of
mine as we embark in this new world
she's just somebody i really admire and
i think should be recognized so abraham
glad you're here
[Applause]
talk eat
what was really fun about that vlog is
i'm really trying to be thoughtful about
giving roses to people while they're
here and what's great about weeks like
nft nyc is people are in town in a world
where everyone's busy getting 15 minutes
scheduled together is [ __ ] impossible
so it's nice for a serendipity and get
to give some love and that's like so
important to give love
heard you don't say none when i hit a
curve you said my tea like it's horrible
watch it come back full circle knew this
life was eternal when i hopped over
hurdles i so universe so you see me with
myself
listen man listen this thing right here
wasn't given i'm whipping this to
precision before you talk homie listen
they love me for my ambition paper chase
palm itching i brag different the flow
ignorant got them hooked they kept
fishing
hey mark what's up brother one of the
reasons it was very easy for me when i
really dug in late last year to believe
in this was actually because of
farmville on facebook
there was two things that happened to me
during that era farmville on facebook oh
my god people are buying these digital
sheep because they want the social
currency to show their friends they're
good at it and then zay frank i don't
know if you remember zay frank remember
zay frank who's one of the first video
bloggers he had people buy virtual ducks
as little tip jars and have their name
hover over it and those were the first
times i was like oh my god people are
gonna buy virtual things virtual
currency in my book thank you economy i
talk a lot about virtual currency in
2010-11 was it natural for you to
believe in what's happening right now
with nfts because of the things like
farmville that happened on your platform
you know i hadn't really thought before
you raised it about you know some of the
the early farmville experiences or or
some of the stuff from from a decade ago
but i think you're right that there is a
clear through line right both between
the the kind of social interactions that
people have and the types of commerce
and obviously there's more technology
now that can make it more interoperable
and that can you know give people more
rights over the goods that they have and
you know on the ar and vr side making it
so people can feel a more realistic
sense of connection but i think you're
right that a lot of these concepts are
not fundamentally new they're sort of
the next iteration on just dynamics that
are evergreen and that are just always
going to be and always have been very
important to people
[Music]
all right gary talk to you see ya
[Music]
flip this garyvee fans here's what you
don't see august 13 paul versus
vaynerchuk what's good
[Music]
how about you my man how are you though
i'm great elliot i was just so excited
about the space and like i got in and i
got it heavy and then i pulled myself
back from it and i was like
do i want that i don't know it's a good
question it's like a rhetorical moral
question for me whereas like do i get
involved and build that world or do i
just build myself and just like
disregard that and be happy with
regardless what i have because i don't
want the chase for the chase i want the
chase for like
for love like
does it make sense of course it doesn't
bother me
so how did you do it personally it's
more intense for me the thing that kind
of makes everything palpable for me is
good intent
i want nothing bad for anybody i want to
make myself happy i want a crazy intent
the intent is to enjoy my daily process
and
for me
and then because i'm good
i can give
[Music]
yeah this is my office i got all my
shots because a lot of this stuff was
kind of like why i think the nft thing
came so natural to me it's kind of been
the way i've always saw the world
[Music]
i do believe there will be many nfts
given as gifts this holiday season we
all saw when like the email with like a
gift card attachment from amazon or
apple was the gift i do think we'll see
the first dozens thousands hundreds of
people waking up christmas morning and
their friend or relative is like hey
check your metamask or your openc
account and boom there's the gift you
know 50 000 people getting an nft this
holiday is actually a remarkable feat
considering pretty much nobody on earth
knew what it was a year ago but in the
scheme of 330 million americans or
whatever the number is these days still
relatively small but i think we get
together a year from today that number
is gonna be hundreds of thousands
potentially
it is not purple today
and all i ever wanted was some real love
then i sit on my heart i watched it
build up
[Music]
till i can't feel it
[Music]
[ __ ]
the thing that really stands out for me
in the difference of web 2 and web 3
with brands is in web 2 everyone in the
audience was building on top of
communication not consumerization so it
was about how we communicated so when
brands came in there was a lot of
pushback because it was business in this
space unless you're a hypocrite i think
we can all agree way too much energy is
about the financial part which i think
is a vulnerability for our space right
now if you look very carefully 80 of the
[ __ ] in this space right now are day
trading digital assets and so
there's nothing wrong with that i love a
good garage sale but
what it does is actually gives brands
subconscious more room to do things
because most people realize they're
having a lot of business dna in what
they're doing as well and if brands play
it right they can benefit from that a
lot more than what happened in o6 when
it was a completely different
conversation and i think that lends
itself to a huge opportunity to all of
you much like i've told you in the
content about getting to influencers on
dm i still believe that this is so hot
and there's so much momentum that
there's somebody who literally launched
a project three weeks ago that can make
a jv with a national bubblegum brand or
a cereal brand and i hope this gave you
some insight to how they're thinking and
i hope everybody here has a tremendous
time this week and i hope everybody
follows my twitter tonight because i'm
throwing a secret wine party which i
haven't done in a decade
i've got a [ __ ] load of wine
i have no idea where i'm doing it and as
soon as i find a spot i'm tweeting it
out so i hope i see every one of you
[ __ ] people tonight thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
he asked a question during my talk and
asked me to come and i said yes and so
i'm like [ __ ] i have to now come yeah i
appreciate it that's high integrity
brother
you're a [ __ ] busy man
[Music]
so much to have you here thank you it's
the first irl mint of your life am i
right firm what does that mean for the
future of this space in your opinion
right now go that other people will do
it too why
because it makes sense right because
gamification of our society will happen
with this infrastructure because if you
can't get this if you don't come well
then you can't get it thus people will
come what that will do is lead to
organizations whether for-profit
non-profit and many other things to
realize that's how humans behave and
thus doing it no different than credit
card points and airline points and the
millions of other things humans done for
a long time except now on a
decentralized authentic transparent
environment this is [ __ ] obvious
figure it out
i was struggling to pay my rent i have
two kids and now i'm the head of a phone
that is ten million dollars and it's
because of you and i'm holding i'm
buying
and i'm doing this because of you and
how much do you have the perfect persian
cat
i just got goosebumps my son clicked on
the button and it was my first ever nft
thank you so much for everything i swear
to god i'm going to repay you by sharing
the love that's what i'll be
real
doing
[Music]
how do i set goals as a creator without
limiting myself that are practical give
me a for instance i want to make sure
i'm capturing your essence let's say i
want to have a million subscribers by
the end of next year that's already a
very dangerous framework because it's an
arbitrary number like why not two why
not 750 000. to me the way to think
about that is i'm going to do these
things that i want to do that i also
think will bring value to them and then
i have to let the chips fall to where
they be whether it's a million five
hundred thousand or four million because
the second you create those arbitrary
goals you become the prisoner to access
the numbers you're the prisoner you
created a jail for yourself for no
[ __ ] reason my guy yeah because it's
still awesome to have ambition i have
unlimited ambition i just don't want to
make it something arbitrary and [ __ ]
something that like can only cause
anxiety
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
come on shirts what's good what's going
on
can i get one
let's go
baby betting
plays out the
bugs what's the problem with being
successful at 39 instead of 26. i think
the biggest issue for me is um i really
want to give back to my parents because
don't you think your parents would be
more upset if you were anxious and
unhappy in the process of potentially
even burning yourself out because you
were so impatient to try to help them it
burnt yourself down yeah i think they
would be sad i think they'd be sad too
so way i got a message be patient cool
thank you how can i like practically
move forward with this my setup like
this is my future this is my goal that i
want to like i fell in love with what
stuff what's stopping you developers and
like not even developers just ideas
who's a developer i got in this space a
couple months ago
there we go we're good next
the reason i did that was you can find a
developer the developers aren't the
problem the problem is either a lack of
patience or a lack of confidence and the
lack of confidence usually comes from
actually caring what everybody here
thinks
well then if you don't give a [ __ ] then
just do it i appreciate you great gotcha
taking a picture with you
but i just want a quick question with
you about this music like i'm an artist
myself i'm trying to get it out here in
the ent spaces just one advice that you
would recommend like just put as much
music on tick tock as humanly as
possible worry about the [ __ ]
blockchain later get leverage of having
a community everything will work itself
out tick-tock window for virality is
going to close the next two years
[ __ ] go as hard as you can on that
platform gotcha got it
[Music]
[Music]
that was [ __ ] crazy
[Music]
props and drops nation what is good
there's a lot of kids in the space right
now who are the champion of nfts in
their family and friend network all
their families and friends told them it
was a scam and [ __ ] and garbage and
they've won they look like the winner if
what happened with internet stocks in
1999 happens with nfts where everything
loses 80 of its value because of a crash
they now are the loser so now the
narrative changes this what happened
with the internet by the way this is
what they said about facebook stock is
what they said about snapchat stock this
happens my concern is these are kids who
are incredibly insecure whose entire
self-esteem is wrapped up right now into
their winning in nft land if and when it
crashes will they have the stability
emotionally to deal with not only oh my
god 80 of my net worth was in these five
nfts and now it's nothing but can they
face their circle i am incredibly
worried about this hence why i keep
saying over and over be thoughtful play
with money that you can afford to lose
don't get caught up in the fomo be
patient don't over flex if you're
winning right now with your friends
because then you're gonna have to
reconcile with that there's a lot of
kids that don't know how to deal with
success you're [ __ ] on your friend
for nine months now they get promoted
they're making 30k more and your [ __ ]
snail and [ __ ] raccoon went from 80k
to 4k i just this is very [ __ ]
important talk
[Music]
discord what's good first access of the
friends happening right now say what's
up what's going on discord tell them who
you are alec hanson modeling podcast
podcast panther holder the first access
token being executed it's a podcast
panther why is perspective important
because it's your actual life nobody's
happy democrats not happy republicans
are not happy 20 year old's not happy 60
years not happy you know why this is
happening right because prosperity is
the gateway to anxiety people have it
too good when you're fighting for food
and shelter you don't give a [ __ ] about
a slang term somebody used that you
think was it like you're just fighting
to live of course you're upset about the
milk that was put in your starbucks your
life is phenomenal
of course you're frustrated that your
wi-fi is out in your house and you can't
watch your netflix show your life is
sensational of course you're mad about
something that somebody said on twitter
you're not running for your life people
had war what the [ __ ]
[Music]
hey everybody it is gary vaynerchuk and
this is die hard dialogue where we pick
a couple of games each week and we let
the die-hards battle it out one of those
games is always the new york jets game
because i am the ultimate new york jets
die hard
[Music]
[Music]
this is a rare
narrow escalator
i like the narrow i think it's more
efficient i think escalators are too
wide i think it's a problem
[Music]
there's a group of us in our age range
east coast style
i'm 45.
i've
um either depending on the circumstance
88 or 12.
i'm being serious
i'm telling you i am i play in two very
extreme realms one the tried and true it
is attention arbitrage whether it's a
[ __ ] song or whether it's tick-tock
it is attention arbitrage there is
nothing else that is the world and then
there's the humanity like i genuinely
believe being nice is a better business
strategy than not so there's some these
things that i would say are religion
they will never change i'll be 90 on
stage and being like i'm telling you
billboard's on the moon that's the
[ __ ] action because that's where the
new attention is so that's the 88 year
old the 12 year old thing is the tactics
like the actual details of how to win on
tick tock like when me and drock just
went up the escalator and i did
something and i turned to him and said
that will do well on tick-tock that's
like a skill of the moment so that's
what i do the macro and the microphone
[Music]
this piece took hundreds of hours
thousands of pieces of broken records
the theme of it is almost the last
supper kind of element with i think some
people that very
highly values and so if you'll drop the
uh curtain there
ah
jeez it's tamara
it's aj it's lizzy and of course
thank you
it's amazing thank you so much
really somebody dude thank you so much
so kind
[Music]
i love everybody has an opinion on nfts
that they're a scam or they're beanie
babies or it's a fad without doing an
hour of homework we have become a
headline reading hot take society that's
a bad strategy for actual business i
think you should change it if you don't
understand the concept of smart
contracts on decentralized blockchain it
will affect your business in the next 10
years the seven people that raise their
hands you can chill a little bit because
you're gonna be golfing and drinking
margaritas the rest of you need to
really focus on 20 to 50 hours of
curiosity and homework and i hope these
minutes together at least gave you
a little something to push it through
and i appreciate all of you so much i
wish you well thank you
wow in a seven year relationship i quit
my job i started to do business
figures and i'm proud of you i'm just
such a huge fan i'm proud of you i'm
sorry no personal conversation no it's
okay it was really worth it you feel
good uh yeah
of yours one day just hit me and i was
like this is not great
good for you i'm proud of you proud of
you to have that courage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i need you
[Music]